simplify 1/2 times the absolute value of
5 minus negative 1 squared minus the
absolute value of negative 3 times 2
squared so this is also an order of
operations problems with a little bit of
absolute value thrown in there for good
measure and just to remind ourselves
order of operations parentheses
parentheses parentheses then we want to
do we want to do exponents exponents
then multiplication and division
multiplication and division and this
doesn't mean that multiplication goes
before division if you have a bunch of
multiplication and division going on you
want to go left to right it just tells
us that multiplication or division will
go before addition and subtraction
addition and subtraction once again this
doesn't mean that addition goes before
subtraction it means that they're at the
same level that multiplication or
division goes before these guys if you
have some combination of addition and
subtraction you want to just go left to
right
so with that out of the way let's
evaluate this expression so let's see
inside of our parentheses so we don't
have I mean we have a 2 inside of a
parentheses that's just going to
evaluate to 2 and negative 3 is going to
value to a negative 3 and negative 1 is
just going to value it to negative 1 so
the parentheses really can't be
simplified a lot more let's move over to
exponents we have 2 squared so we're
gonna do that we're gonna square the 2
before we multiply it times negative 3
so 2 squared that's going to be a 4 and
then before taking this exponent over
here we'd be easier to simplify this
over here so let's do that first so we
could just do that let's see inside of
here you can almost do the the absolute
value signs of parentheses you're taking
the parentheses and then you're going to
have to evaluate this expression and
then you're going to take the out its
absolute value so this thing right here
5 minus negative 1 we know that when you
subtract a negative number that's the
same thing as adding the positive
version of it so this is the same thing
as 5 plus 1 this is the same thing as 5
plus 1 which will evaluate to 6 so let's
just rewrite what we have just so we
don't get too confused so this is now
1/2 times the absolute value of
six squared minus the absolute value of
negative 3 times 4 negative 3 times 4
now the absolute value of 6 is clearly 6
6 squared is going to be 36 so this part
right here it'll become 1/2 times 36 and
then over here we have a minus we have
in in that in the absolute value sign
negative 3 times 4 is negative 12
now what we want to do we want to do
multiplication before we do any
subtraction over here so we can safely
do this multiplication first
I could put parentheses around let's
just show you that we'll do it first so
1/2 times 36 that is going to be 18 and
so we have 18 minus the absolute value
of 12
well what's sorry 18 minus the absolute
value of negative 12 what's the absolute
value of negative 2 well it's 12 so it's
going to be 18 minus 12 which is equal
to 6 and we are done